Trump's back up Trump's back up what
let's play hard on
no if he got a heart I mean he's oh
Trump in order
my candidacy for president of the United
States
I love the breaking news at the bottom
Trump expected to announce presidential
but at any moment like yeah he just did
it [__] ticker get with it ticker
you're [__] behind the times
yeah ticker's almost like that autistic
buddy you have uh-huh a ticker and that
was always a name they had for somebody
who had autism or whatever a ticker
because he's a tick ticker button
hey Button where is this tell them
button Mar-A-Lago
it's Mara Lago what do you think about
this he's gonna win right
what do you think I don't know I don't
follow politics at all so I'm following
much either it does it is interesting
because I like the tears of the of the
righteous and man this guy makes him
flow
it's fun for me to walk their tears were
you even when you saw Dave Chappelle
saying that did you see that bit that he
talked about Trump he goes I'm not I
remember him before he goes but when he
was running he goes I'm not going to
vote for him
I'll vote for Hillary but I don't like
it yeah you know yeah do you see that
can you find that clip Zach where he
said the other day during his SNL thing
about what they why people liked Trump
which is the original Trump now damn so
he's eight years past where he was
before he was already old then
you think he's still [__]
yeah you think Trump's still [__] I
think one of his top goals I think he's
getting probably ex-homes and stem cells
into that it's probably smart to take
the four years off because then you
extend you know your time being at the
top you're on four all four but that all
four you're still former president he's
still a g and then on four again and
then the next four you adjust the
president so you really get 16 years out
of that if you run it right and you get
to bounce back and kind of like see
whatever didn't work maybe the first
time I don't know if in Trump's case
he's able to do that you know what Trump
you should change the Constitution to to
eight consecutive years so that way you
can you can do it eight full years this
time
that's what Hitler did that's what
Hitler did rewrite that Constitution did
he yeah you really got that Constitution
anything goes did it in Ecuador too
rewrite the Constitution damn yeah
Ecuador huh yeah I knew a real liberal
comic and she couldn't understand she
was like what the [__] when Trump won
and uh and I was like well you've never
gotten under your limo you've never gone
to Dayton these people are depressed and
they're looking for answers you you've
never talked to them you live in your
[__] gated apartment building
you know when no one's allowed in you
have your [__] doorman wearing an SS
outfit yeah like you have no idea what a
human is like so you're like what like
right right you've sheltered yourself
yeah look on Zach look on Twitter please
where they look at um Chappelle SNL
Trump
this is what I thought was interesting
he said
some people don't understand why people
like Trump he goes when he first was in
the debates
that's so funny well they and they asked
him about the the media went so far
overboard and tried to discredit them
that they eventually got caught like
just misleading the truth yeah remember
that Russia thing never was anything not
always never anything was invented by
Hillary Clinton's side so let's just say
she didn't know but it was invented by a
democratic side and pushed so that then
they never go oh [__] maybe we got to
look at these Liars over here they just
go move past it so it was like if you're
not going to apologize it's like if you
tell me you're going to pick me up from
the airport and then you don't and you
never apologize
I don't think you're gonna pick me up
from the airport next time I can't trust
you're gonna do it if you said dude I'm
so sorry my alarm didn't go off it's
like I can tell you're sorry yeah but
these people never owned up to anything
I did and so it's like I heard I was
randomly in my car and I was listening
to Trump on like NPR during the State of
the Union Address or something and he
goes uh this MS-13 this [__] group
from Mexico is like the drug dealers and
[__] Smugglers and those are terrible
people they're they're they're gang
members
um and they're rapists and you know
they're terrible people and then the
headline I was like oh what the hell
they're gonna play the headline next day
is Trump calls Mexicans rapists yeah and
I'm like damn it's not a lie but it sure
ain't the truth and eventually I did it
so many times we're like we don't
believe you guys that's the thing that I
originally thought was fascinating about
Trump I'm like he's not a politician
he's not a politician so he has the
chance at least if it's possible just
speak real to get in there and and do at
least
put shine of some sort of light on
whatever we don't know yeah because he's
not one of the two sides he's not part
of the [__] Garden yeah everybody's
looking out for himself and business
interests too much it's too bad you get
sort of an evil one in there without
doing that if it would have been
somebody else it could have been
interesting Bernie maybe or somebody
who's like hey come on we gotta help me
let's get these guys out of prison yeah
she's talking normal not like and we're
gonna take her and we're gonna go to the
Washington and we're gonna change it all
over there it's like [__] you you ain't
one of us yeah
yeah I think he got then I think his I
think at that point something they just
wanted to change I think people like
[__] the system that's what they want
they wanted [__] that that's what how
come all these billionaires got more
billions during covet when we're all
suffering I know who's doing that and
rich people making Rich laws for rich
people yeah I can't afford a lawyer when
I get arrested they just have my
retainer so of course they're gonna get
off easy well it does start to feel in
the world like we gotta go to where
they're doing it we gotta climb some
walls we're gonna take care of business
yeah but it's not the guy I feel like it
used to feel like the government was the
best I don't know if I I think the
government's bought out right by the
businesses they're one step down yeah
the businesses put the government in
charge to like keep us all going that's
what it seems like right yeah yeah it's
like an owner and then the government is
like the government's like managerial
they're like supervisors that's what it
feels like yeah yeah like they'll get
theirs too you know they'll make sure to
get theirs but they're not the real ones
right they're just kind of a liaison now
between big business and human regular
regular folks yeah yeah that's what it
feels like anyway not to be a downer but
that's that right there is what I
thought was fascinating about Trump from
the beginning was like [__] maybe
there's a chance where she goes when she
goes uh you're cheating on a taxi goes I
know I'd be a fool not to yeah what do
you mean yeah I have great [__] taxes
attorneys the rest of that clip there
might be it might be on there
that was basically the end of that club
okay
well okay
see and that could be we don't know if
it is or not but that could be it's not
out of context book no just big digital
telling us that's the end of this that's
enough I got a call it's actually the
end of the clip yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one